how's gum raspberry ah welcome now
minute I'm so excited this game just
came out with the long-awaited DLC which
is called Octodad shorts so as you can
see bear - here we are don't dad romance
and medical mess let's start with dad
Roma's conception sounds amazing I'm so
excited
alright here we go I don't even remember
how to play this Jesus way I switch
between there okay all right walk into
the club like what's up hey girlfriend
hello there welcome sir hi what name is
your reservation under umm thanks mom
that purple that kind of sounds like
what I don't see a totally on judy's
perhaps I'd see more clearly if I had a
little a little cash a little bribe
alright I see how it is you want plenty
or take plenty
you don't want plenty well how about how
about this fancy suit that I found you
want it got damnit I'm stick
I was really oh Jesus sorry guys just
lucky whoops
just oh hi I'm so sorry I got him stuck
I need to go out of here
alright search pocket for cash I can't
find anything I'm stuck it's literally
stuck now alright well I guess we search
these jackets is that it oh my god it's
raining damn alright alright awesome oh
sorry make it rain on them hoes sorry
sorry good that we have a table for two
after all it doesn't even get it alright
come here babe let's sit down I mean
this way of course sorry um don't mind
me just doing yoga it's my thing I love
yoga sorry about hitting your little
baby your waiter will be with you
shortly
move near your chair and use your arms
to say
so good yes it does keep a definitely
quite exquisite isn't it do you
exquisite go through people's stuff to
learn everything there is to know about
them what do you mean
alright check the menu alright alright
got did got it got it
there we go not have best one oh the
paper didn't pay me to write that war
story come to think of it I suppose I
should submit an application now that
I've got some experience raise hand to a
waiter over waiter please excuse me
waiter
the perks of being an octopus waiter
waiter waiter y-yeah
come on Tommy Matt Thank You Don don't
decide yet I want to try ordering for
both of us
ah see if I've got you figured out yeah
she's gonna order squid or something
before mmm-hmm you'll find out good
evening
I'm Alan care of you tonight are we
ready to order yes yes I'd like the
sirloin Oh he'd like the halibut all
right excellent choice that's fine thank
you
act casual Howard just don't get it
what's not casual about staring into it
you're not here after all
try drinking some water okay I've heard
that about oysters but I didn't know
about hagfish slime
how do I drink it I love water today sir
more water please
oh sure love water hey we should toast
yes of course when my foot no wait at my
hand oh you know clink glasses together
wish something well good thing I have
physics on my side and before of course
have I mentioned how much I great let's
toast it's far away come here I want to
toast you up there we go try drinking
some whoops another one please my
muscles okay I love you just keep
staring into the table so lonely and
miserable wash up in the mesh room all
right um
excuse me I'm just gonna go to the
bathroom I are you great to see you here
Gary
this gets we put them out to the tip all
right we're sir
there we go zero percent that's a great
amount of tip that's what we do in
Sweden we don't tip [ __ ] all right where
do I pay I mean wash up that's what I'm
doing right hi how do I wash up exactly
like I sell I'll just take a dip huh
what do I hot water oh there we go
damn oh boy a fish you get uh yeah fish
get sorry all right
ah sorry um go in the boat into kitchen
where we clean up after you sorry sorry
about that
sorry about that here you are sorry
about dad was beginning to wonder if
you'd fallen in I did actually
it's gonna how you say that wait get to
the kitchen
why sorry again lady I got my duty hi
tonight mix the sauce why do I have to
do it what the [ __ ] are I fine I'm an
octopus and I have my duties to mix [ __ ]
up yes that's right sauce you're gonna
be the best damn sauce that I ever saw
in my saucy life yes
nailed it stomp grapes for fresh juice
of course what else would an octopus do
that's not disgusting at all I'm a stump
you one time me plus you have a stamp
you 110 fill jug with juice all right
no no no no no no oh god [ __ ] up I meant
Jew I need that gosh done thank you and
all right now I need you in my life
come on how much shoes do you need baby
come on baby come on girl
how much youth you want girl what do you
want from me
it's not filling up anymore there we go
thank you find you and Scarlets juice
glass why do I have to do all this it
ain't pay fill the Scarlets and okay so
I better bring the juice all right here
we go I'll just have to him I'll take a
shortcut cuz we're kind of at a time
here now juice what did you do yeah I'm
coming juice don't worry dad done Japan
it hi oh Jesus
such a boss at disk hmm okay let's not
spill all the juice hey my love I was
beginning to wonder if you've fallen in
uh no I'm fine don't even worry about it
Oh God it's got it sit down
we should go out dancing Saturday night
hey there you go rule you want some of
this girl you want some of this
yes right hey it looks like a [ __ ]
potion or some [ __ ] I am I sitting
anyway I can't reach it's not fair
yes whoo but I thought I was sitting job
I'm not sitting are you serious I was
just not sitting all right here we go
Rose we got this easy I'm so comfortable
sorry about that
all right here we go food is here act
normal darling don't embarrass me
enjoy the butter and eat bread oh god I
sit there ha about white glue oh I don't
like talking still playing strong silent
type a cup salt dealers the old man in
the sea didn't take you for the room
novel type alright I bought in my bread
a little whoops and then I eat it I
think no I dance with it oh I eat it
alright cool hey lover boy the curves
other customers before you get your
flare bomb what the [ __ ] are they
talking about
take boof couples order hmm what it was
that even mean I'm stuck no no I'm stuck
no I came this far not to get Jack no
Jim
sorry that's it please no oh sorry lady
we did it oh sorry
I'm coming honey uh what's the order
from these people all right I am the
actor dad I will be taking your dairy
cow your little with behind you years
what do I have to do all day Nick let's
see what you've got there you go you
want salad
I mean pepper I give you all Zee peppers
I make the peppers shake you guys like
pepper that's fine as long as it's not
Sam pepper oh that's good
oh I went there I went there all right
how much pepper do you want Wow girl you
crazy a little more enough all right
that is good ziggety unless you serve
such fancy cake to the table near the
entrance any time I will get a chance to
serve a fancy cake I will ride that cake
to victory all right follow me cake Oh
Paula make a who wanted to play oh they
want it all right hey who's the birthday
girl hey hey hey how you doing oh
they're up and I just get it sir this
King to you good thing my my woman
doesn't see me I have wallah Saheb jaan
cake
Zack ate the cake Kayla good all right
up sorry
up no not up now look [ __ ] follow the
cake
stop that cake
there we go oh thank god uh you guys
need to chill the [ __ ] out
alright I have your [ __ ] cake I think
oh sorry I didn't mean to beat you with
the cake that's that's wasn't my there
we go chop chop chop chop
you're welcome
hey babe sorry I have my duty to make
sure everyone feels good tonight
including you later if you know what I
mean
laters every girl stains all over their
shoes I should investigate that now what
is he doing with my cake bladder wall
nobody it is appetizers oh Sh
I can't what's the most haunted place
you've ever been an exhausting to be me
I just keep staring at my junk Wow sorry
lady I need to get back to the kitchen
for some [ __ ] reason oh my god the
chef was looking for you Axl cooking
yoga practice all right steak steak get
a steak out of the fridge um thank you
in there
no thank you not a way now you possibly
done cooking ah you smell a puss all
right and octave no wait up that then
okay anyway here we go
I got you baby wait tenderize steak with
mullet what is that oh all right hope
you don't see me I'm sure I'm gonna need
that later but [ __ ] it life's handing
your lemons to make lemonade then oh god
what happened to my getaway yeah yeah
back back back back by the hammer of
Thor I shall tenderize you cool all
right that's that's good that's good
give me that meat Oh fresh meat cook the
steak in a skillet is that what they
call that in America is skillet is it
because it takes skilled no wait
make sense oh nice
this is how we cook steak and Sweden
baby get up there man I'll just cook it
with my hand there we go
what toss the pizza dough oh come on
like how how do I toss it oh okay that's
cool
spread sauce pizza all right this is
pretty this is making me pretty hungry
and I got a lie
sprinkle cheese where's the cheese the
way it's latchet Alta Sanyo there you
are
you stupid cheese something you can
choose your way out of this you [ __ ]
that's right I know your true intentions
me and the pros have you figured out
good
there we go sprinkle make it rain make
it rain make it rain on the pro now cook
the pizza hmm some people like to use
that wooden thing so you don't burn your
arms I'm a real man I don't need to do
that [ __ ] I done really come on load the
dishwasher why no one is telling me to
do this well [ __ ] you
why do I have to do everything in lab oh
alright well that helps actually well I
guess white why not you too yes and
voila c'est bien sûr good doctor pots no
close close ah stay I said stay oh yes
no why no ah I hate you yes woo
brings a pizza to the couple I'm sure
this restaurant is approved by hell fees
standards and stuff so that's what am i
doing
let go there we go who's who wanted
awarded a pizza oh you did alright still
coming right there you want your pizza
I'll look the Italian couple one in the
Pico that's cute
Pizza you're welcome I made it with love
literally my sauce is in there my love
sauce is in there hey babe
stay back that just needed it there we
go I'm so comfortable people people
never realize how you really sit in a
chair oh you're not the only one with
secrets yes I've been doing some digging
and Samata what the [ __ ] happened in my
way if you could be any kind of animal
Bruno an octopus a human oh that's a
silly answer see like a like a mean
woman I don't even need to look while
eating you know how much kung fu skills
this took for me to figure out there we
go please
I think God the solid part is over I was
there awesome where the finished tables
Jesus all right watch it who finished
who finished which Wow
just these okay that's easy done oh god
what happened
no what am i doing over here sorry guys
don't worry about that uh that was just
the tank done that's how you clean like
a met is that a fish oh that's my Jim
Gary Gary how did you get here but you
need to come back the ocean mrs. shut up
Gary no no one's gonna stop me from
getting laid Gary all right back
Scarlett I was talking to a fish nope
you're wrong don't even worry about it
just run it be but be here for you there
we go hey babe I'm sitting like Britney
Spears style I hope you can enjoy it do
you think I look kawaii salt my fish
ah they just had to [ __ ] put it there
huh
come on oh god I can't
gotcha why do I have to make it so hard
for myself I could have just not salted
fish but new alright now one alright cut
it
use your fork to eat it the fish oh no
ok it works nice pretty good actually I
could eat it yeah oh thank god this is
so hard
catching again
mine got frickin child slavery labor oh
god what did you do what did give you aa
for some reason I can't hide in water
real really real it's a dance party oh
you all right where's the [ __ ] mom
there's me
oh god make it stop I have a go this is
high I'm off in Sweden every oh god what
happened to you
why oh why what's the problem with us
what's her problem with a fire the
mopping is obviously first priority all
right fine how did this restaurant
manage without me how how if thanks
Oh God all right I wish I could forget
dessert but what are you gonna do
what were your what that no what are you
doing now my desert
stop how do I get it from there
come back here desert I got you whoo all
right
scarlet I'm coming nothing's gonna stop
me from getting laid
nothing here we go okay Scarlett I just
uh uh take the desert hey you're welcome
I'm just gonna chill here care for a
taste it's pretty good isn't it
blobbing in agreement and it's romantic
that is so romantic
David do dirty with the other pros we
did it all right that was awesome
we got one more to do for us please like
if you want to see the next one
I really appreciate it and I'll see you
there that's always stay awesome bros
love you